[Musique]
ce sont des militaires qui gardent en
permanence l'ancien blue parrot le tout
premier hôtel de playa del carmen sur la
riviera maya
ce haut lieu du tourisme mexicain n'a
pas survécu à la fusillade qui en
janvier dernier a fait quatre morts dont
deux touristes et un employés canadiens
et 15 blessés depuis le blue parrot est
barricadé et toute la station balnéaire
est sous tension car la violence n'a pas
diminué
le chef de la police municipale a été
renvoyé et remplacé par cet ancien
militaire tout s'explique dit il par une
guerre entre bandes rivales qui se
battent pour cette zone de la ville en
fête pour le marché de la drogue dans la
fameuse cinquième avenue où se concentre
le gros du tourisme oui on a un problème
qui le chef de police et on doit on va
le résoudre
la violence est telle que le département
d'état américain a ajouté à ses
avertissements sur le mexique l'état de
quintana roo les homicides ont augmenté
en 2010 est dans des batailles entre
groupes criminels et des passants
innocents ont été blessés ou tués dans
des fusillades
cancun et la riviera maya c'est la
première destination touristique
d'amérique latine
ces 16 millions de touristes par pour la
moitié étrangers surtout américaines une
entrée en devises de lui milliards de
doll ces cinq millions d'emplois dans la
région
le tourisme c'est sacré pour le mexique
nous avons rendez vous avec le
professeur henri gonzalez qui anime tous
les jours sur carré bfm
l'émission de radio la plus écoutée de
la région avec des entrevues de fond le
carrosse en test dans le programme reste
bloquée ce dernier revienne et de la
musique
sauf que l'animateur était curieux de
savoir ce qu'on pense à l'étranger des
violences actuelles dans la région et
yann michel de la radio et télévision du
canada
si bien que nous sommes retrouvés à
poser nos questions ou participant de
l'émission en direct à la radio avant
d'y répondre à l'aise certains corps
policiers protégés des groupes criminels
compresser des scones argonautes propose
une protection
ils ne sont plus protégés maintenant
alors ils se battent entre eux pour le
marché de la drogue
avant il y avait un seul grand cartel
celui de sinaloa
depuis que son chef le chapo guzmán est
en prison aux états unis
le cartel a éclaté et au moins trois
groupes se battent pour le territoire
ça a commencé sous l'ancien gouverneur
de kinta narrow roberto bord s il est en
prison pour corruption et blanchiment
d'argent dit roger et il attend son
extradition du panama nous avons
contacté des principaux politiciens
locaux
en vain ils se sont tous des filets mais
pas la police sous l'ancien gouverneur
les polices de l'état et des
municipalités ont été privés de
ressources
le lieutenant colonel de l'armée qui
dirige depuis trois mois la police de
cancun dit qu'il n'avait pas les moyens
de contenir la criminalité croissante
depuis un an
par contre elle pour la citation talent
banda sultan de cancun on est à plus de
120 assassinat en 2017
le matin même il y a une autre fusillade
dans un des quartiers chauds de cancun
mais jusqu'ici aucun touriste étranger
n'a été touché l'état la ville et le
gouvernement fédéral met le paquet
maintenant les touristes peuvent revenir
d'une chef de police qui
nous allons assurer leur sécurité et
l'améliorer sous peu non seulement pour
eux mais aussi pour notre population
peu de touristes dans la zone hôtelière
c'est encore la base saison mais les
associations hôtelières admettre une
baisse des réservations en provenance
des états unis même s'ils sont discrets
les hôteliers sont inquiet ce n'est pas
le cas de ce tourisme montréalais n'en a
pas de danger ces annonces à mu en fait
ce que nous avons tous été corrects avec
l'apprenez c'est tout
ces surveillants pour rester dans la
zone hôtelière géant veloci normal n'en
vois aucun problème
c'est comme toutes les autres la police
touristique est omniprésente
son chef discute avec le gérant d'une
boîte de nuit qui a été attaqué il ya
quelques jours
personal en tentant
ni délinquance organisa une affaire
personnelle dit le lieutenant carlos
bustos pas de crime organisé la zone
hôtelière est sûre affirme-t-il et nous
allons travailler pour qu'elle le reste
et lorsque banal on aurait aussi croit
que la situation s'améliore sauf lors de
la fusillade du blue coat aucun touriste
n'a su faire dit il on détermine son
programme et tous concluent les
touristes peuvent venir sans danger
aucun dans un nouveau canal
même que le canada doit cette chanteuse
a suscité
[Musique]
le mexique connaît la pire vague
d'homicides des 5 dernières années et
pour la première fois cette violence
touchent la riviera maya
cette mecque on reste optimiste tout le
monde ici veut croire que personne pas
même les narcos ne voudrait tuer la
poule aux oeufs d'or
[Musique]